[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission on
parle cuisine alimentation agriculture
écologie mais aussi politique et cette
semaine nous recevons Stéphane Manigold
bonjour bienvenue merci à vous d'être là
et avec moi pour présenter cette
émission Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour
Jean-Pierre bonjour Brigitte bonjour
Stéphane Manigold bonjour les amis j'ai
l'impression d'être au bureau là
c'est mon bureau vous êtes le
restaurateur parisien en vue au 5
étoiles Michelin avec le groupe éclore
vous possédez 6 tables comme la maison
Rostand le Flaubert liquide l'oiseau
rive gauche et braise mais on vous
connaît surtout pour avoir fait plier
les assurances pendant le covid votre
combat acharné contre AXA vous a permis
d'être indemnisé pour vos pertes
d'exploitation ça inspiré un livre vivre
ses rêves afin de rêver de sa vie votre
parcours est pour le moins sinueux
enfant de la DASS vous déployez une
énergie et un mental de fer qui vous
donne des ailes à 11 ans vous travaillez
dans une fête foraine puis vous devenez
animateur radio DJ ou encore responsable
grand compte automobile chez Audi vous
avez été également livreur de pizza
alors un indice Jean-Pierre pas vraiment
ça c'était sa vie d'avant adieu l'Italie
bonjour Paris bonjour Paris et même
bonjour La Bresse puisqu'on va déguster
grâce à vous une fricassée de volaille
de bresse au vin jaune accompagné d'une
purée truffée et on desserre Brigitte on
aura droit à une le noir et noir ça ça
doit être votre côté mulhousien
absolument dans le dessous des plats
coco et boulanger de Paris dans les
pieds dans le plat vers Noël 100 fois
gras la grippe aviaire a décimer les
élevages il y en aura donc pas pour tout
le monde
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
[Musique]
allez Stéphane je le dis franchement
sans emballage je sens un peu de
revanche sociale dans ce repas que vous
avez eu la générosité de nous préparer
et oui en revanche sur la galère de
votre enfance Brigitte l'a dit la ZUP le
taf de l'adolescence des parents fauchés
un placement au foyer mais au bout de ce
parcours minet en mode résilience sa
façon Bernard Tapie le boss vous vous
êtes forgé un nom et une réputation dans
la gastronomie mais chez vous pas
question de luxe gratuit et ostentatoire
pas de bling bling pour nous en mettre
plein la vue avec avalanche Brigitte de
caviar et de langouste non on sent le
vécu avec ce poulet puré sans saveur
cadeau vous ne pouviez plus voir en
peinture et qu'aujourd'hui avec vos
étoiles sur le tablier vous transformez
avec la grâce de la volaille de Bresse
et la magie de la truffe qui vient
sublimer la patate la voilà donc votre
idée Stéphane du Fast we comme marqueur
social de votre appartenance mais non
pas une classe supérieure et blindée
j'allais dire mais à une caste
d'irréductible gourmet est-ce que je me
trompe
respecter merci pour pour ce portrait
mais c'est avant tout nos terroirs sont
absolument magnifiques la France est
belle donc vive la France et la France
regorge de richesse alors c'est vrai
j'ai pas eu le plaisir de
très bien manger disons-le mais cette
revanche aujourd'hui je peux la voir
grâce grâce à mes chefs et d'ailleurs
cette volaille devrait
qui a été préparé par le chef Nicolas
Baumel je suis très heureux parce qu'au
fond derrière le fond d'écran c'est
l'intérêt qu'on a racheté en 2020 c'est
exactement c'est la maison et j'avais vu
c'est mon bureau donc et donc merci à
Nicolas Baumann d'avoir préparé préparé
ce plat et Victoria bolaire qui est la
première femme chef du groupe qui a
intégré et quand va lancer pas très loin
d'ici donc oui le hasard a du talent
comme dit que Lelouch il suffit de
d'ouvrir les yeux donc
j'essaye d'ouvrir les yeux à chaque fois
que le hasard passe pour pouvoir en
profiter vous voyez le hasard fait que
je suis ici derrière c'est mon bureau et
nous ouvrons dans pas longtemps une
table gastronomique et la première femme
chef du groupe qu'on installe au pied du
pouvoir juste à côté de l'Assemblée
nationale alors ça c'est un plat
signature dans l'un de vos restaurants
pas du tout je voulais vraiment partager
avec vous un repas de fête
de Noël autour d'une volaille de Brest
avec vous et celles et ceux qui nous
regardent pour pouvoir au fond qu'on
peut faire quelque chose de
d'extraordinaire dans un budget
totalement
la truffe elle est volontaire je ne
l'aurais pas mis en temps normal mais
les volontaires c'est pour vous dire à
quel point la truffe c'est un c'est
extraordinaire c'est c'est champignon
naturel le poulet la meilleure saison de
la truffe c'est après les fêtes il
faudrait décaler Noël et Nouvel An en
janvier pour en profiter pleinement que
les consommateurs et dans le monde
entier souhaitent consommer de la truffe
pendant les fêtes ce n'est pas là où
elle est la meilleure et c'est surtout
là où elle est la plus chère là la
concentration du 3 terroirs puisque vous
avez prononcé ce mot il y a donc le Jura
le Périgord et puis le et puis la braise
donc c'est la conjonction c'est trois
terroirs qui viennent donner ce plat
formidable et puis la patate et la
patate
Île-de-France l'Île-de-France
nous sommes sur 4 terroirisation je vous
en prie vous allez nous dire si c'est à
votre goût
moi je quand je goûte en fait un plat je
coupe toujours séparément chaque
ingrédient
là dans un printemps la garniture la
sauce
voilà on est
on est démarre en Île-de-France on va
dans le Jura avec un vin jaune du Jura
du domaine relais
le vin que vous nous avez apporté alors
vous l'avez dans la sauce et puis le
meilleur accord au fond c'est un accord
de terroir et là on a une sauce au vin
jaune alors évidemment j'ai voulu vous
emmener sur un vin du Jura également
toujours de ce domaine pour rester dans
la cohérence et un petit clin d'oeil à
nos bleus qui sont en finale avec
millésime 98 98
donc à la France à notre santé à la
santé de celles et ceux qui nous
regardent qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
Stéphane Manigold fricassée pour nos
téléspectateurs qui sont faire une
politique mais aussi de cuisine une
fricassée de volaille ça veut dire qu'on
l'a d'abord fait revenir avant de la
faire cuire un peu à l'étouffer oui en
fait on a arsé le chef Nicolas Bohem
d'avoir le plus beau métier du monde
c'est-à-dire que je me pose à table et
je goûte ce que mes sublime donc c'est
les étoiles 1 leur appartiennent c'est
le travail oui je juge et je juge au
fond la qualité du produit parce que le
bon ne peut se faire qu'avec le meilleur
et il se trouve qu'en France on est un
pays où on a le meilleur partout dans
toutes les régions chez les producteurs
vous allez un peu à leur rencontre vous
testez alors Michel vont principalement
eux chez les producteurs
alimentaires de fruits de légumes des
éleveurs de volailles et moi je j'essaie
de grande passion pour les artisans
ternaires donc je vais régulièrement
chez nos amis vignerons que je salue et
qui font la fierté aussi de la France
parce que il n'y a pas de grand
restaurant s'il n'y a pas d'artisans
Terre-Mère exceptionnel et la France est
un terroir magnifique naturellement
composé d'ailleurs je peux vous raconter
le petit anecdote sur les terroirs de la
Champagne par exemple puisqu'on est sur
un événement festif savez-vous ce qui a
dessiné au fond tout le terroir viticole
français et bien c'est la ville de Paris
qui qui était qui produit un
affaissement et cet affaissement a
provoqué un séisme et ça a dessiné du
nord au sud de l'est à l'ouest tout le
vignoble français et c'est pour ça qu'on
a un terroir absolument magnifique
naturel qui qui est d'ailleurs c'est en
scène c'est là un vigneron champenois
qui m'avait raconté cette histoire on
était sur
sur une de ces
lieux-dix qui s'appelle les karelles et
il nous avait fait observer justement
cette il me dit voilà là-bas tu as Paris
et là tu vas vers le sud est à ce
vignoble qui s'est dessiné donc on a une
richesse incroyable est-ce que on trouve
toujours du local est-ce qu'on trouve
toujours du bio chez chez vous dans vos
restaurants on trouve du local
évidemment bio c'est un voilà on n'est
pas très adepte en fait de ce qui est
mode le mode pour vous le bio non parce
que le vigneron ou l'artisan il fait du
bon et non on cherche celui qui fait du
bon celui qui respecte la nature celui
qui au fond c'est pas parce qu'il a un
label que c'est forcément
pas meilleur c'est pas ça renforce pas
le goût c'est pas plus plus naturel ça a
pas le non parce que non non pas
forcément c'est c'est des critères en
fait qui sont édités je vous donne un
exemple les vignerons par exemple
lorsqu'ils vendant ils peuvent en manger
bio mais la nature est bien faite et on
s'aime c'est l'OS par exemple me raconte
que lui vendange en lune descendante
pourquoi parce que la lune quand elle
monte le remonte dans le raisin et donc
le concentre en eau et lorsque la lune
est descendante l'eau redescend et là on
a le fruit et bien lui par exemple la
biodynamie en fait exactement et donc et
donc au fond le meilleur bio c'est
l'agriculteur c'est le vigneron c'est
l'artisanat c'est lui qui sait c'est pas
l'Europe c'est lui qui sait Stéphane la
pomme de terre parce que on a pas bien
vu mais il y a aussi de la purée c'est
populaire
de la truffe avec elle comme quelle
pomme de terre vous l'avez réalisé alors
avec une très vieille variété qui est la
Mona Lisa qui est une vieille variété et
elle est pas qu'au musée
oui mais c'est la plus ancienne alors
elle est moins connue que la Beach ou
l'agréa moi j'aime beaucoup la Mona Lisa
donc voilà alors trois choses à savoir
sur la sur la purée bien réussir sa
purée parce que c'est un plat qu'on
mange au restaurant dans les très bonnes
tables parce que les truffés parce
qu'elle est très bien faite mais on peut
faire une très bonne purée alors quels
sont les astuces alors d'abord il faut
des pommes de terre à chair ferme
surtout pas cher ferme mais à cher
plutôt farineuse vous l'avez dit comme
la Binche mais il y a aussi la samba la
Gatta la marabel la Mona Lisa qui a été
utilisée pour cette purée effectivement
la chair farineuse va donner plus de
texture à votre purée la cuisson il y a
un débat avec ou sans la peau en gardant
la peau vous conservez un peu les
nutriments et surtout vous gorgez moins
vos pommes de terre d'où elles sont
moins aqueuses donc c'est plus facile
ensuite quand vous rajoutez votre beurre
votre crème ou votre huile d'olive et
bien de l'Allier toujours une cuisson à
froid et avec des pommes de terre de
même taille afin que la cuisson soit
assez bien répartie enfin comment
l'écraser et bien c'est là le
presse-purée le fameux presse-purée
qu'on doit avoir tous chez soi ou la
fourchette surtout pas de mixeur car ça
va faire une purée un peu collante et
effectivement si vous n'avez pas des
truffes moi je vous conseille pour faire
une purée de fête et bien ajouté un peu
de beurre truffé et ça peut faire la
blague parfois ou des champignons de
Paris ou des champignons de Paris encore
un grand plaisir moi j'ai une autre
recette sur la purée alors c'est la
mienne c'est surtout pas celle de mes
chefs qui bouge leurs oreilles parce
qu'ils vont pas aimer on écoute moi je
prends un lait il est très bonne des
enfants adorent je prends un lait entier
surtout pas écrémé et je culpa mes
pommes de terre dans de l'eau mais dans
du lait OK et donc ça va adoucir et avec
la peau et moi j'aime bien la presser
avec la peau et ensuite évidemment je
rajoute un un bomber vous gardez la peau
je garde la peau moi j'aime bien ça ça
donne aussi une coloration il faut bien
nettoyer alors oui alors faut oui il
faut avec une avec une brosse faut les
frotter pour enlever le sable d'une
purée réussie c'est beaucoup de beurre
non
pas forcément parce que quand vous
l'accueillez dans du lait entier et bien
vous gardez ce lait dans votre casserole
avec la purée et vous et vous l'écrasez
à ce moment-là donc vous rajoutez un peu
moins de beurre puisqu'il y a
naturellement et puis comme vous le
laisse se chargent absolument qui
devient un peu crémeux aussi et je
rebondis sur la question de Brigitte la
purée Robuchon c'est pas votre c'est pas
votre purée préféré comme tout je l'ai
essayé avec de la rate du Touquet et
puis autant d'heures
je goûte beaucoup j'ai un vagastronomie
ça commence à se vendre de mes costumes
donc voilà vous disiez que vous goûtiez
avec vos chefs est-ce que vous
participez au menu est-ce que vous
investissez là-dedans je goûte vraiment
mes chefs ont une pleine liberté ils
sont déjà associés ils sont c'est dans
dans mon groupe en fait c'est un lieu un
chef une histoire et on va identifier
des jeunes talents
on va les mettre en place et on va aller
faire éclore d'où le nom de mon groupe
éclore parce que je crois en escalier
social j'en viens et je dis escalier
parce qu'au fond l'ascenseur social vous
avez plus un bouton ça monte tout seul
l'escalier il faut faire quand même un
effort quand vous prenez des escaliers
et moi j'habite au 10e étage et quand on
prenait l'effort on le faisait pour
monter les 10 étages et donc j'aime bien
cette notion de un de confiance en cette
jeunesse parce qu'il faut croire en la
jeunesse elle regorge d'énergie on le
voit et bien transformons cette énergie
en énergie positive j'aime l'énergie
positive j'aime pas les énergies
négatives d'ailleurs mon cerveau il est
pas conditionné pour la négation c'est
quelque chose qui me qui m'exaspère mes
équipes le savent d'ailleurs je salue
tous ceux qui sont venus nous
accompagner et préparer ce joli repas
c'est magnifique vous avez un très beau
restaurant je voulais pas vous vous
faire une cuisine micro-onde etc donc on
a ramené des plaques pour les
téléspectateurs de cuisson des poils des
cocottes pour pouvoir vous préparer sur
un métier qui est en perpétuelle
évolution est-ce que vous avez vu les
cartes évoluer est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous voyez les consommateurs changer
sous vos yeux manger peut-être moins de
viande plus végétarien comment vous vous
ressentez les choses alors là vous
essayez c'est une perche extraordinaire
vous savez que je suis un fervent
défenseur de l'artisanat et de la
gasoiles mais vraiment et je vais
prendre l'exemple de nos amis italiens
de le dire mais en Italie on peut manger
mieux partout
c'est qu'en Italie quand vous commandez
sur Internet
ubereat délivrez ou quand vous allez
dans un restaurant vous ouvrez la carte
et bien lorsque c'est industriel ou
surgelé c'est noté ça fait toute la
différence en France quand on fait bien
faut sortir la fanfare il faut le fait
maison le label bio le Lab il y a 15000
labels en France il y a trop de la belle
faisons simple allons à l'essentiel et
je profite d'être sur la Chaîne
Parlementaire si les parlementaires
c'est très simple maintenant c'est ou du
réglementaire ou mais c'est tellement du
bon sens et il y a pas fait maison non
oui mais il faut le marquer c'est normal
quand on va dans un restaurant que ce
soit fait maison ce qui n'est pas normal
c'est l'industriel et le surgelé et
d'ailleurs je demande même au
gouvernement au député de rehausser la
TVA dans nos métiers sur ces produits
spécifiquement de la remettre à 20%
parce que la TVA ça veut dire taxe sur
la valeur ajoutée quelle valeur ajoutée
y a-t-il à prendre un produit surgelé le
mettre dans un micro-ondes le dresser
sur une assiette émette un petit bout de
persil aucune donc ça ça doit être taxé
à 20 %. donc je demande vraiment à ce
que nous parlementaires réhausse la taxe
sur ces produits là surgelés et
industriels de façon ce que on sort
parce qu'on connaît tous dans nos villes
on va pas là-bas c'est un piège à
touristes mais bien souvent ce piège à
tourisme c'est parce qu'il n'a que de
l'industriel et que du surgelé ou que du
surgelé et à un moment on est soi-même
touriste et on peut pas accueillir
demain de grands événements comme la
Coupe du monde de rugby les Jeux
Olympiques nous sommes une fierté la
France qui est en finale et accueillir
le monde entier et lui faire goûter une
cuisine qui n'est pas la nôtre qui n'est
pas faite dans ce qui fait rayonner la
France et je rappelle que le repas
gastronomique des Français est inscrit
au patrimoine du métal de l'UNESCO
depuis 2008 et donc faut que ça change
message passé à nos parlementaires on va
voir si vous êtes vraiment incollable à
présent c'est le quiz
alors je sais que vous êtes un fan de
boeuf Stroganov un ragoût aigre doux
avec du paprika mais nous allons savoir
si vous savez tout de ce plat mythique
aux origines russes incertaine en
démêlant le vrai du faux donc je vais
vous raconter 4 histoires sur le bœuf
Stroganov et vous me direz si c'est vrai
ou faux il serait né dans les cuisines
de la richissime famili russe des
Stroganov mais deux comptes se disputent
sa paternité Pavel Alexandrovitch et
Alexandre Grigo riewic est-ce que c'est
vrai ou faux
écoutez moi je suis un vrai fin gourmet
il l'histoire du boeuf Strogonov c'est
ma marraine qui préparait des spets
sur une sur une sur une planche en bois
et je la voyais couper ses cheveux secs
et son couteau et là vous faites
diversion
et donc en fait j'ai c'est madeleine de
Proust et comme toute madeleine de
Proust vous avez pas forcément de
connaître l'histoire mais donc vous
allez me la prendre parce que je la
connais pas alors est-ce que c'est vrai
que deux comptes se disputent la
paternité oh c'est possible et ben oui
c'est vrai alors c'est un Chef français
André Dupont avec un nom pareil on peut
être que français qui aurait mis au
point la recette originelle vrai ou faux
cocorico c'est un forcément un Chef
français qui avait ce merveilleux plat
c'est vrai
[Musique]
laquelle de ces quatre pizzas ne fait
pas partie du répertoire napolitain
c'est celle qui me parle le moins c'est
la deuxième mais voilà c'est bon bravo
c'est quasiment 100% de réussite ce qui
est assez rare on sent le fin
restaurateur
son sixième sens Bernard tapied on a
trois secondes pour plaire on a trois
secondes pour pour interpréter voilà
j'essaie de ma curiosité vous étiez
pizzaïolo quand vous travaillez dans une
pizza
livreur et ça c'est en été et quand j'ai
vu le froid arrivé et la pluie sur la
phobie que je me tire en cuisine
je suis allé faire des pizzas alors vous
savez qu'en France le repas occupe une
assez large place et c'est souvent
autour d'un bon repas que ce nous les
meilleures histoires que se fait la
petite et la grande histoire c'est la
brève de comptoir
et donc on vous a demandé Stéphane
Manigold réfléchir à une anecdote
politique autour d'un repas vous avez un
souvenir j'en ai plusieurs je voulais
vous raconter celle de François Fillon
mais je vais pas prendre celle-ci je
vais prendre une autre avec avec une
députée qui était Président de la
Commission de la gastronomie c'était
Barbara de sobalo qui n'est plus député
aujourd'hui mais qui m'avait invité en
tant que président de la commission
gastronomique
Le Meur qui est toujours député à
l'Assemblée nationale au huitième pour
un repas et échanger sur sur des textes
de protection de nos métiers
ça a été une catastrophe en termes de
repas et je le dis mesdames messieurs
les députés regardez vos factures
vous voyez la transparence sur le
produit surgelé etc bon il faut que y
compris au 8e étage la gastronomie
française le terroir français national
à des prix à des prix quand même plutôt
élevés
moi je trouve que c'est très cher je
vais très dur peut-être avec le chef
mais je trouve qu'il y a un peu trop
d'industrie à mon goût
là-bas je pense que par exemple les
l'ail les échalotes c'est déjà broyé
surgelés les sauces elles sont en poudre
mais peut-être qu'il va faire un démenti
dire le contraire mais voilà j'ai pas
passé un bon moment et je trouvais que
les Parisiens j'avais pris des des côtes
d'agneau
avec un autre député qui m'a invité
d'ailleurs pour la sortie de mon livre
qui est le député d'assaut Victor
aberdasso qui m'a invité et j'ai
retrouvé les mêmes éléments
industriels dans l'assiette donc voilà
la transparence ça doit aller aussi à
l'Assemblée nationale j'avais changé
d'ailleurs avec Guillaume Gomez sur ce
sujet et il se trouve que le label
mettre restaurateur ne peut pas être mis
dans les collectivités il ne peut être
que mis dans des restaurants commerciaux
donc dans les collectifs ça peut pas
nous faut que ça évolue ça aussi vous
avez un peu mis à la bouche avec
François Fillon vous pouvez pas nous
raconter l'anecdote alors il était
toujours dans la valorisation de il est
en pleine campagne et je voyais à
certains noms de candidats et on avait
organisé à la maison un repas avec une
trentaine de de personnes et je me
cassais la tête et je dis mais qu'est-ce
que je peux faire un ancien Premier
ministre qui a dû goûter tous les plats
possibles et imaginables avec un
huissier qui doit lui touiller son son
jus de jus d'orange pour être sûr que la
pulpe se mélange bien enfin je dis
qu'est-ce que je vais en fait au final
j'ai fait venir des élèves de l'école
Ferrandi pour valoriser la cuisine et la
salle de Ferrandi merveilleuse école
française dont je suis fier qui en plus
dans sa circonscription qui ne
connaissait pas et on lui a fait tout
simplement on lui a fait tout simplement
un steak frites un steak frites
restaurateur qui ça d'un restaurant
William berner d'un restaurant qui
s'appelle le cerveau on mange à steak
frites extraordinaire dans le 14e et
donc je l'ai fait venir et avec les
élèves de faire en dit on le fait un
steak frites il en a repris il était
émerveillé
aussi non ah c'est oui ça c'est un
ancien boucher vous avez raison et ça
fait 40 ans qui malheureusement ça la ça
l'a pas fait gagner oh non ça c'est la
politique après on va parler d'un autre
aliment à présent que vous connaissez
bien c'est la baguette produit français
par excellence mais aussi aliment
incontournable de la table elle est avec
nous pour ce repas c'est le dessous des
plats
[Musique]
6 milliards de baguettes sortent des
fournils chaque année 12 millions de
consommateurs poussent la porte d'une
boulangerie chaque jour la baguette
rythme la vie des français et en plus
elle s'exporte un succès qui lui a valu
tout récemment son inscription au
patrimoine immatériel de l'Unesco
reportane reportage Diane karcher
en matière de baguette personne ne s'y
connaît mieux que Frédéric Comines grâce
à son pain de nombreuses fois primés il
est fournisseur officiel de l'Elysée
voici selon lui les critères d'une
baguette d'exception qu'elle est faite
avec amour ça c'est la principale des
choses en fait ensuite elle a une très
longue fermentation c'est à dire 48
heures elle est croustillante on peut
entendre
voilà elle est bien dose jolie elle est
très belle pas de secret dans la pâte de
la farine locale du sel de la levure de
l'eau et du levain c'est la fermentation
qui fait tout 48 heures sous haute
surveillance fermentation c'est très
précis on respecte des températures des
temps pour que ce soit vraiment qu'on
est vraiment au maximum le développement
du bouquin romantique voilà pour la
partie technique mais en boutique les
clients le soulignent dans la baguette
il y a aussi de l'émotion une baguette
bien cuite s'il vous plaît c'est
intéressant pour le pays pour le
l'environnement pour le monde entier
devant tout le monde dire que la
baguette est la meilleure celle de
France est la meilleure
cocorico cocorico quand vous dites bien
sûr pour Emmanuel Macron c'est aussi une
certaine idée de la France en voyage
officiel à Washington il s'est affiché
baguette à la main et n'a pas caché sa
satisfaction de voir cet emblème
consacrée par l'UNESCO c'est des rêves
qu'on offre à nos enfants leur montrant
que tout au bas de l'échelle
mais avec des jours et des nuits en
apprenant ses savoir-faire qui sont
passés demain en main qui viennent du
fin fond des siècles
parce qu'on compte pas ces jours et ses
nuits
on a un produit qui est inimitable et
ses rêves s'exportent jusqu'au Japon
depuis ses 13 ans Maina rosawa rêvait de
fabriquer son pain à sa quoi je passais
devant la boulangerie je me disais ah ça
sent tellement bon à ce moment-là j'ai
décidé de venir boulangère pour y
arriver elle vient se former en France
en 2016 un an plus tard elle serre la
main d'Emmanuel Macron en tant que
première étrangère et première femme à
remporté le prix de la meilleure
baguette tradition aujourd'hui quand
elle est de passage au Japon c'est
l'affluence pour acheter ses produits
c'est le pain de la Nouvelle Star
boulangère la plus remarquable en ce
moment la clientèle c'est des gens qui
adorent la France
sanitaire parce qu'on est tout ça et
sans satisfaites ça me fait plaisir de
voir ça 11000 boulangeries ont déjà
fleuri ici vendu 2 euros pièce la
baguette s'est fait sa place au Japon
Stéphane manigole c'est une fierté que
la baguette soit inscrite maintenant au
patrimoine mondial immatériel de
l'Unesco
la baguette finit quand même le repas je
vous ai vu tout à l'heure cher
Jean-Pierre Sausset
la recette et la méthode c'est une
méthode de fabrication qui a été qui
était classique ou la protéger parce que
aujourd'hui nos amis boulanger mais
comme beaucoup d'artisans sont secoués
par cette crise énergétique qui est
puissante violente et qui risque de
faire disparaître ce patron dites nous
dans vos restaurants vous fabriquez
votre votre propre pain ou vous
l'achetez à une boulangerie à côté alors
on fait travailler des boulangers de
quartier alors soit on met des recettes
en place avec l'artisan boulanger ce qui
est le cas par exemple d'un
établissement qui se trouve chez nous à
granit dans dans le premier
arrondissement de Paris un jeune chef
jurassien comme meilleur qui vient
d'être qui a pris son étoile cette année
et qui vient d'être titré du Meilleur
Ouvrier de France serait fier très beau
palmarès très beau chef qui va
éclore il a commencé mais qui va
continuer avec leur donc ça je suis
heureux et donc et dans un établissement
avant même que la baguette soit glacée
au patrimoine immatérial de l'UNESCO
dans un nouvel établissement au pied de
l'Élysée nous avons remis la baguette
sur table pour nos clients dans un stock
qui s'appelle braise Berry et ce pour
les Bretons ensuite désolé
mais Paris c'est entre la Bretagne et
l'Alsace donc ça va et donc on a on a
remis la baguette dès le mois de
septembre dans cet établissement parce
que j'avais envie de
consommateurs d'avoir retrouvé cette
baguette qui fait la fierté à
l'international par exemple dans votre
doses j'imagine que vous savez pas que
de la baguette les Français sont assez
friands aussi d'autres d'autres pains et
maintenant peut-être même un peu plus
difficile sur des dépenses sésame aux
pavot j'aime beaucoup farine j'ai
beaucoup peur au maïs dans un
établissement nous avons mis à la fois
un pas tradition c'est les les pains
paysans un peu bleus tranchées au levain
exactement et un pain au maïs parce que
j'aime beaucoup le la texture le le côté
gourmand du pain maïs et je fais un
exercice peut-être aussi pour la
clientèle qui n'aime pas le gluten aussi
peut-être non alors absolument j'ai pas
quelques intolérances
j'ai pas la chance d'avoir la malchance
pardon d'avoir cette allergie bon je vis
très bien avec mais oui c'est ça ça
correspond aussi à une attente et une
demande d'ailleurs c'est lorsqu'on met
du Formalis c'est par gourmandise le
client c'est il tient j'en ai pas goûté
je vais goûter donc c'est quasiment ce
qu'on passe le plus depuis 1970 il y a
000 comment boulangerie qui ont fermé
est-ce que vous avez peur que ce soit un
savoir-faire qui se perde parce que là
on a l'impression c'est cocorico ça
s'exporte en Asie et pourtant et
pourtant il y a moins de boulangerie il
y a des pas industriels on parlait de
des produits industriels tout à l'heure
ce qui est indiscret c'est pas forcément
mauvais je dis juste que le consommateur
doit le savoir et les boulangers ont
réussi c'est pareil extraordinaire que
ne peut s'appeler boulanger que celui
qui pétrit les cuisses en bas sur place
c'est quand même la différence
Jean-Pierre entre un pain industriel et
un pas un boulangerie ben parce que déjà
c'est marqué boulangerie un pain
industriel un industriel ne peut pas
afficher boulanger sur sur son
place donc justement il fait venir une
baguette toute faite qui réchauffe
simplement non mais maintenant on a
assisté auxquels Brigitte faisait
allusion a des espèces surtout en dans
les zones périphériques des grandes
boulangeries à des ronds-points où ils
font leur pain et le cuisent sur place
c'est très aspect un peu industriel mais
finalement le pain il est pas si mauvais
que ça au est-ce qu'on est obligé
d'avoir une toute petite boulangerie
avec
je suis attristé parce que
le nom de ce groupe mais
cette industriel dont vous parlez
l'éclosion de certaines boulangeries
justement d'un d'un gros industriel
c'est presque un milliard aujourd'hui de
chiffre d'affaires c'est colossal quand
une baguette tourne autour d'un euro
vous imaginez ce sera présente un
milliard de chiffre d'affaires les
procédés qui ont été mis en place pour
cuire 1000 baguettes à l'heure c'est du
délire c'est on s'éloigne en fait de ce
que doit être l'artisanat pour laisser
place à l'industrie la France
le monde entier vient goûter la France
et cette chance de voyager que aux
États-Unis et que ce soit on a d'en
parler tout à l'heure en Italie partout
et à chaque fois quand je dis voilà j'ai
des restaurants à Paris et toi Paris la
France ça me manque et la crise du covid
c'est que les Américains sont menacés et
la première chose exactement la première
chose qui nous disent c'est il se
précipite dans les restaurants goûter
nos vins goûter nos le talent de chefs
et cette France là j'ai peur mais il
faut que ça change que les étrangers
n'aiment plus que les propres résidents
français en tout cas on aime la France
dans la protège pas assez
l'Italie j'en parlais tout à l'heure il
y a Domino's Pizza qui a voulu
s'installer en Italie parce qu'il y a la
transparence Domino's Pizza a perdu près
d'un milliard d'euros d'investissement
pour s'installer en Italie ils ont dû
fermer et son repartis pourquoi parce
que le gamin quand il va manger une
pizza de la mama où c'est tout est fait
maison tout est fait y compris la sauce
tomate tout est fait sur place et bien
il a le goût de l'Italie il a le goût de
la vraie pizza y compris de la margarita
et quand Domino's Pizza arrive et que
vous avez toute une liste industrielle
merguez industrielle mergué
avec mes enfants comme les enfants sont
rentrés à la maison j'ai raconté le McDo
quick attention mais comme les enfants
sont à la maison à papa tu nous emmènes
pas à manger tout nos copains vont
manger chez lui que McDo je vois pas de
problème je vous emmener bah par contre
on a fait les meilleurs burgers de Paris
et on émet alors on est même allé
chercher Cyril Lignac qui était là et
l'Île-de-France est producteur de pommes
de terre on peut pas
mettre dans la bouche de nos enfants des
produits sains où ils peuvent aller voir
pas très longtemps et elle nous disait
que pour les cantines de Paris
effectivement les cantines de Paris
étaient provisionnées de plus en plus en
bio en local et cuisiner sur place
si cette transparence sur les cartes est
mise également sur les cantines
scolaires c'est-à-dire que non tant que
parents quand on voit les menus de la
semaine le semenier de nos enfants et
qu'on voit industriel surgelés
industriel surgelés on va tous écrire
aux maires vous êtes gentil mais moi mon
fils je veux pas lui donner ça vous
allez vous êtes gentil c'est bio c'est
tout ce que vous voulez mais ça va de
l'autre bout de la planète et puis c'est
surgelé donc j'en veux pas et bien
croyez moi qu'en mettant la transparence
y compris dans les cartes des menus des
comptines scolaires partout en mettant
de la transparence partout sur tout ce
qu'on a ingurgite et bien croyez-moi que
on aura un meilleur palais mener le
combat contre AXA pendant la crise du
covid aujourd'hui on voit et vous le
j'ai référence il y a quelques instants
les boulangers les bouchers aussi qui
manifestent dans la rue qui sont
inquiets de voir ces prix de l'énergie
qui augmentent il y a beaucoup d'aides
qui ont été apportées par le
gouvernement est-ce que aujourd'hui vous
qui avez soutenu ce combat pour les
restaurateurs vous comprenez le combat
des boulangers et des bouchers est-ce
qu'il est justifié mais c'est un combat
commun parce que nous sommes également
nous en tant que restaurateur impacté
j'ai régulièrement et je déjeune avec
comme quoi tout se fait autour d'un bon
repas avec le président des du syndicat
des indépendants j'ai eu le syndicat des
boulangers au téléphone en tout cas des
représentants des boulangers qui qui
sont dans cette situation nous avons les
mêmes problématiques pourquoi parce que
je l'ai dit d'ailleurs elle a reconnu
d'ailleurs publiquement l'hiver Grégoire
notre ministre en septembre j'étais le
premier à l'alerté sur la définition
même de ce qu'est une TPE une TPE en
France c'est comme ça c'est une
particularité c'est moins de 2 millions
d'euros moins de 10 salariés
un artisan la règle elle est simple que
son boulangerie ou dans la restauration
et bien par tranche de 100.000 euros il
a besoin d'un salarié donc vous imaginez
bien que pour faire 2 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires donc un million
950 000 il lui faut 20 salariés et je
vais donner l'exemple d'un de mes
établissements qui est sur le trait un
million 950 000 donc il pourrait rentrer
dans le bouclier
énergétique comme les particuliers
d'ailleurs bouquet tarifaires
et moi pour faire ce chiffre là j'ai un
meilleur ouvrier de France on a une
étoile
17 salariés et parce qu'il faut former 5
ça fait 20 critères pour obtenir
totalement
et bien les boulangers c'est pareil j'ai
un ami à Nice qui fait 500 000 euros de
chiffre d'affaires qui rentrent
largement dans les critères de
l'artisanat et de ce qu'est une petite
très petite entreprise mais pour faire
ces 500.000 euros il a 7 salariés donc
là il cote la deuxième case mais il ne
coche pas la case du compteur du
compteur chez vous ou chez nous à la
maison qu'on a un tarif bleu c'est
normal on n'est pas des professionnels
quand on reçoit 20 personnes à la maison
c'est le bout du monde
et bien donc vous avez un tarif le moins
de 36 kWh quand on est un artisan un
boulanger ou un restaurateur bah ça
passe pas ou alors vous faites la
cuisine micro-ondes ah il y a pas de
problème micro-ondes c'est comme la
maison pour un médecin 10 vous serez pas
au tarif jaune et en plus vous avez une
autre sanction qui sera ajoute nous dans
le groupe depuis 2018 on a fait le choix
de la transition énergétique
c'est-à-dire qu'on a supprimé par tout
le gaz dans tous nos établissements à
supprimer un gaz pour aller vers une
énergie propre qui est l'électricité
donc le nucléaire depuis 2018 on n'a pas
attendu que ce soit la mode et bien
parce qu'on a supprimé le gaz et bien on
a augmenté notre puissance énergétique
vous voyez vous êtes vertueux vous êtes
engagé et il y a cette incompréhension
de tout diesel je ne vous crois pas
20 ans d'automobile le tout électrique
n'est pas pour des coupures de courant
cet hiver parce que c'est au restaurant
soit en panne si c'est des coupures
écoutez
je regarde tous les jours
bonne nouvelle nous pourrons voir la
finale il y aura pas de coupure donc on
pourra voir le match pleinement en 2023
vous êtes inquiétez pas oui c'est
forcément une inquiétude parce que
on a des produits frais qui ne peuvent
pas avoir de rupture de chef du froid et
puis on a du matériel électrique enfin
électrique des chambres des chambres
froides
pour faire du gasoil parce qu'on a
découpé on a écouté j'ai confiance les
entreprises il faut le saluer on fait
des efforts considérables pour baisser
l'énergie et au seuil de 10% on y est
déjà pourquoi parce que nous sommes
toute la génération qui arrive donc je
fais partie nous sommes dans des
démarches non pas marketer mais
vertueuses vous voyez bien que la
transition énergique qu'on l'a amorcée
en 2018 on n'était pas dans la crise et
la volonté de faire les choses donc nous
sommes nombreux à avoir amorcé cette
transition énergétique parce que nous
sommes des chefs d'entreprise
responsables c'est pas du marketing
c'est c'est vraiment des convictions
profondes que l'on a alors on poursuit
notre repas de Noël et on va parler du
foie gras il y en aura-t-il sur les
tables ou pas on en parle et on met les
pieds dans le
alors à votre question j'ai mené
l'enquête Brigitte il y aura sans doute
du foie gras sur l'étape de Noël mais
comptez plutôt sur des blocs et des
terrines déjà précaires préparés car
trouver un foie gras frais de canard ou
d'oie relève de l'exploit sur toute
canard la faute à la grippe aviaire qui
a décimé des élevages entiers et des
millions de canards c'est une enquête de
Baptiste garguichartier
c'est une des traditions de la foire au
gras le coup de sifflet le marché de
Samatan a ouvert ses portes mais cette
année le prix du foie gras fait l'objet
de toutes les attentions ici jusqu'à 60
euros le kilo des visiteurs parfois
déboussolés même s'ils sont très jolis
je trouve quand même que c'est assez
excessif donc on va attendre
à côté prix à cause des prix on renonce
il y a pas beaucoup de choix d'habitude
il y a la grande salle si tout est
ouvert il y a du il y a beaucoup de
monde alors je pense qu'il y aura pas du
canard pour tout le monde à l'origine de
cette hausse la grippe aviaire qui
touche massivement les producteurs ces
quatre derniers mois plus d'un million
de volailles abattu conséquences les
prix grimpent plus 15 % en un an
un peu plus au nord à Brive-la-Gaillarde
autre marché à l'approche des fêtes les
producteurs sont certes sur qui vivent
mais sont au bord de la pénurie
tout le monde mangera pas du foie gras
en France cette année on tourne à peu
près nous avec 40 ou 50% de ce qu'on a
habituellement voilà donc ce matin on
avait par exemple aucun foie frais à la
vente deux ans de grippe aviaire toute
une filière d'impacter donc en témoigne
ce cliché un élevage de Bretagne vide
une seule salle de gavage en surchauffe
5000 canards venus de Bulgarie de Vendée
huit fois moins que d'habitude dicter de
ce producteur il y avait pas non plus de
canard sur le marché en tant que il y a
pas de bébé canard ni de prête à gaver
pour pouvoir travailler dans des
conditions normales en moyenne la
production de foie gras a acheté de 30%
en France mais dans l'heure c'est moins
80% pour cette structure familiale une
véritable course à la réservation du
jamais vu
les seuls foie gras que l'on peut
apercevoir sont déjà réservés pour des
gens qui ont passé commande pour huit
Français sur 10 le foie gras est un
incontournable des fêtes de Noël en
cette fin d'année il faudra donc le
partager
[Musique]
alors Stéphane question basique est-ce
que vous resteront sur infectés par
cette pénurie qui a l'air d'exister sur
le foie gras est-ce que vous allez
pouvoir en servir sur vos tables ou
c'est quelque chose que vous ne mettez
plus à la carte ou au menu écoutez
permettez-moi d'avoir une pensée pour
nos éleveurs parce que ceux qui sont
réellement affectés par cette crise
absolument tragique ce sont des canards
on est on est simplement là pour
sublimer ce que l'éleveur a fait de
façon absolument magnifique donc
vraiment je pense à tous ces éleveurs à
tous les drames qui en découlent parce
que c'est c'est ça fait partie pour moi
du patrimoine français non déplaise à
certaines personnes qui veulent
interdire ou qui l'ont interdit dans
leur mairie je prends en tant qu'
alsacien à Strasbourg je partage
absolument pas
oui nous-mêmes on est concerné dans le
cadre de nos achats on continue à
soutenir nos éleveurs un état oui on a
on a des demandes alors par exemple on a
un chef mathiasmach donc à substance qui
qui en plus ambassadeur de de de de du
foie gras mais vos chefs ont vous-même
les terrines c'est des terrines faites
ah oui en fait
on fait tous sauf le vin l'eau et le
pain voilà comme ça c'est simple tout le
reste en fait tout ce que vous mangez
vous avez connu une pénurie de foie gras
fraîche on parlait tout à l'heure il
paraît c'est vrai que vous avez du mal
c'est un drame très élevé paraît-il
alors non seulement les prix sont très
élevés et on a beaucoup de clients qui
nous demandent est-ce que tu peux nous
avoir du foie gras euh nous en faire
donc là on a un chef à substance qui a
on a péniblement pu acheter 20 kg
installateur 20 kg euh auprès d'une
ferme voilà donc vous avez dû changer de
filière ou vous apprenez
totalement hein
on a vocation quand même à soutenir nos
agriculteurs quand ça se passe bien mais
aussi quand il subit des drames et quand
il subissent des drames nous sommes pas
des opportunistes t'en va pas aller
on leur demande simplement ce qui
peuvent nous livrer on le reçoit avec
avait beaucoup de joie et après
l'Alsacien que je suis c'est aussi faire
du foie gras d'oie qui a été importé
exactement qui a été importé par la
communauté juive on Egypte et qui est
revenu en Alsace et qui a qui a inventé
ce foie alors ceux du Sud-Ouest et nous
le canard le premier en tant qu'assassin
je considère que le foie gras a été
inventé par les enfin importer d'Egypte
par la communauté juive en Alsace vous
avez dit magnifique produits ça veut
dire que vous le gavage ça vous choque
pas comme pratique le bien-être animal
le bien-être du canard vous y pensez
moins que la sécurité économique de
l'éleveur de canard non c'est pas ça je
pense que pour avoir visité alors
principalement des des élevages d'oie
quand j'étais petit et aujourd'hui des
élevages de canards non vraiment ce sont
des éleveurs qui aiment leur bête et qui
les respectent quand on lui met dans le
plus de maïs qui n'en veut vous êtes
peut-être dans dans
l'industrialisation mais l'éleveur qui
respecte ces canards et ses voix oui il
va lui mettre il va évanouir mais soit
il perd trop fier devient grave ça c'est
enfin nous on a le même fonctionnement
si on commence à nous gaver et qu'à un
moment on va
est vraiment toujours dans le bien-être
animal c'est aujourd'hui un terme qui
est très très employé est-ce que ce
qu'on n'est pas la limite là sur le
gavage des oies je sais pas non non
parce que ça fait partie de notre
patrimoine de notre terroir je crois que
il faut pas tout moraliser il faut aussi
un moment enfin
limite attention les droits de l'homme
le droit animal évidemment mais là la
maltraitance animale les animaux
domestiques etc mais mes lois ou le
canard ce sont des des techniques qui
sont ancestrales on parle de 1400 1500
donc ça même avant donc vous voyez c'est
je sais pas moi je suis pas je suis pas
à l'aise avec la moralisation sur tous
les sujets je crois qu'il y a des
patrimoine il faut savoir préserver et
et ça fait aussi la Ferté de notre pays
et puis sur plan marketing c'est quand
même un génie celui qui a inventé ce ce
foie gras parce qu'aujourd'hui X et gras
c'est deux mots que tout le monde fuient
à la base et puis on en a fait quelque
chose de noble quelque chose que le
monde entier vos envies alors nous nous
laissons pas fragiliser par par la
richesse de notre patrimoine assumons
notre patrimoine on a des contradictions
il faut juste de temps en temps les
assumer moi j'assume que je défends pas
de moins en moins vous dans vos
restaurants vous avez pas l'impression
qu'il commande moins de foie gras qu'ils
ont veulent moins pas du tout pas de
réflexion pas du tout au contraire au
contraire mais le monde entier vient
chez nous par ça je crois que c'est ici
parce qu'il peut pas manger chez eux
par Royaume-Uni pas au Danemark donc il
y a quand même une tendance il y a des
pays qui interdisent le foie gras mais
est-ce que c'est une tendance ou c'est
fragilisation d'un pays et de son
patrimoine on est plus sur des sujets de
guerre économique de guerre culturelle
etc la France c'est la gastronomie c'est
c'est nos terroirs c'est nos territoires
c'est nos agriculteurs c'est nos paysans
moi je suis petit fils de paysan
d'ailleurs mes grands-parents étaient
éleveurs et quand j'étais pas quand ma
grand-mère demande à mon père si j'étais
gentil ou pas et que mon père avait le
malheur de dire non et bien je finissais
un cage avec les oies qui me courir
après c'est mort ça mord pas ça passe
mais je vais venir sur les fesses quand
ça trappe c'est pas un va donc on parle
de foie gras vegan vous vous bandissez
bah pourquoi déjà il a pas le foie gras
dans ce cas-là assumer moi j'assume des
contradictions je l'assume bah eux
qu'ils assument qu'ils arrêtent
d'appeler merguez quelque chose et belle
merguez qu'ils arrêtent les bacon
notamment foie gras ou à la merguez il
faut j'ai fait l'expérience
dans le 17e il y a une influenceuse qui
a ouvert un
ce qu'on appelle de la porn foot
c'est-à-dire les trucs un peu gras un
peu oui oui en photo des burgers mais il
faut vivre avec son temps et du coup
avec mes enfants j'ai goûté j'étais un
dimanche j'avais goûté cette c'était bon
c'était bon poulet aux champignons enfin
à la base c'était du champignon donc
reconstitué
mais j'ai bu 4 litres d'eau c'est trop
salé mais c'est hyper salé mais parce
que pour reproduire du bacon qui n'en
est pas avec le côté fumé etc mais vous
booster en sel et donc en fait on nous
explique que
c'est bon pour les cardiologues mais
c'est pas forcément bon pour la santé et
puis il y a une chose qu'on a transmise
c'est en Creuse ça tombe avec ses dents
et bien bonjour mais arrêtons de de
manger des espèces d'airsas de je ne
sais quoi la nature est bien faite
pose la question sur le vegan moi je
pose une question une réponse très
courte parce qu'on est pressé mais le
foie gras naturel sans gavage vous savez
parce que c'était les oiseaux migrateurs
qui avaient l'habitude de conserver un
peu d'énergie dans leur foi pour
traverser les mers et les pays et ça
vous l'avez déjà goûté c'est des fois
gras moins gros qui sont moins gras vous
l'avez goûté ça déjà vous trouvez ça
bien non non on essaie de goûter
maintenant
on est dans le bien animal parce qu'on a
utilisé les pouvoirs de l'animal
lui-même
je vais le goûter
à présent et c'est le péché mignon
oui voici venu le temps du sucré
Brigitte avec un détour en Allemagne
proche de votre Alsace natale pour un
dessert mythique la Forêt Noire créée
par des Allemands en pleine guerre en
1915 gâteau germanique créé en 1915 donc
à base de génoise cacaoté imbibé de
kirsch c'est l'alcool c'est l'alcool de
cerise et recouvert de ces petits
copeaux cacaotés qui ont donné
d'ailleurs le nom à ce gâteau parce que
c'est sombre et c'est noir et ça fait
penser soi-disant à la Forêt Noire
est-ce que c'est et l'Allemagne est-ce
que c'est le souvenir de vos
déplacements là entre Mulhouse et
l'Allemagne cette forêt noire c'est un
souvenir de de ma grand-mère d'adoption
qui avait dans son jardin des cerises
qu'elle cueillait lorsque c'était la
saison et qu'elle faisait alors on les
mange mais elle émettait on avait
beaucoup imbibée au Kirch donc c'est
propre
cerise imbibée et puis elle faisait son
propre alcool parce que vous savez qu'en
Alsace on a des petites dérogations
pour faire nos retours on s'auto régule
sur le consommation et on est très
locavore en Alsace et ma grand-mère qui
avait son son grand ses grands
radiateurs c'est en fonte elle faisait
gonfler cette génoise au chocolat
qu'elle imbibé régulièrement de kirsch
ça je l'ai senti vous voyez si vous
sentez on sent beaucoup le chocolat mais
pas assez le kirsch donc pour moi ça
donne vraiment imbibé pendant 48 heures
elle faisait elle faisait monter cette
génoise et elle imbibée de kirsch on
continue et elle arrivait avec ce
torchon mouillé
repas et moi je mangeais très peu
pendant pour savourer ce dessert qui est
ma madeleine de Proust elle vous a aidé
la recette non mais elle serait
impossible à reproduire comme toute
Madeleine de Bruce d'ailleurs ce qu'il
faudrait le il faudrait les cerisiers
dans le jardin il faudra le en fonte et
le bon dosage qui est naturel je
confirme sont plus le chocolat goûter
Brigitte on sent plus le chocolat que le
kirsch et alors et une autre chose dans
dans les codes de du cercle absolument
tout se mange avec la Fourchette sauf la
soupe même la glace pourquoi parce que
quand je peux prendre votre cuillère je
vais vous montrer je vais vous montrer
une chose je voudrais la différence mais
c'est pas grave il y a du bon vivant
là-dessus vous voyez là là c'est plein
et donc quand vous mettez en bouche le
palais il est au contact de l'inox de
l'argenterie enfin ça dépend
et vous avez le produit systématiquement
donc tout se mange à la fourchette donc
je vous invite à vivre l'expérience y
compris sur la glace sauf la soupe et la
cuillère elle sert juste à pousser
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro de politique à table sur LCP